alors bérengère vous allez me dire si je
me trompe
un moment il y avait du ticket de métro
maintenant c'est ce qu'on appelle la
titeuf patinoire c'est la petite mèche
comme ça et c'est release and the city
jô dur et les éditions c'est un accident
c'est une bêtise quand j'ai lu ça dans
un magazine féminin vous à leur et celle
à titeuf
j'vous l'dit
pour les films vous normalement là mais
je vous l'avais déjà n a plus qu à
l'allumer double mais non merci matthieu
delormeau non mais voilà non manille
alors vous vous avez le poil ce qu'on
appelle le poil velcro non lui il est
bien il a le poil et par exactement ce
que ces pratiques
ah oui c'est vrai aussi que je voulais
passer ici j'ai laissé pousser je
ressemble la vraie la foule mandchoue
non mais c'est le traître asiatiques il
a des poils non c'est pas ça veut dire
qu on a mis un petit polar bipolaire
éléments du mans oui ac oui c'est ça le
match tarbes où vous êtes et pilote
également je vous ai vu banon mais
totalement imberbe ah oui même de quoi
ah oui oui on voulait pas le savoir